michelle what's up all right so my
husband and i
are current family while my husband
completes military training okay our
family that we're staying with
they have a 17 year old daughter who has
come to both me and my husband
with she's telling us that she's got
some depression
and that she needs help however one
parent
is indifferent about the situation while
the other
seems to be resistant because we're
being told that she finds it
embarrassing
that her daughter needs help um so my
husband and i we don't
know what to do because you know it's
daughter's underage
uh we're staying with family they're you
know gracious for letting us stay in
their home
and we don't know what to do without
crossing the line but
making sure that we get this girl help
yeah yikes man talk about
not by your hand but in your lap so um
when she comes to you and says she's got
depression walk me through that and what
i'm
getting at is on number one overarching
everything i'll make sure she's safe
she's not gonna hurt herself
she is not in a abusive situation so
when she says
i'm not um i've got depression i need
help what does she mean by that
so she's she's seeking help in from a
therapist
or that's the main thing that it seems
like that she's wanting
um however she has told my husband and i
that she's had thoughts of doing
something just to get herself committed
so that she could do
or could get help and we both feel that
she is not going to do anything to
herself just because we've
made ourselves there for her and she
comes to us to talk when she's having
really bad days
but it's gotten to the point where she
has mentioned
doing something just to get herself the
help that she's needing
because her parents aren't signing off
on
you know any type of therapy or anything
like that
and walk me back to the conversation
you've had is this
is this your family or your husband's
family
it's my husband's family okay so walk me
back to a conversation you've had with
one of the family members that said i'm
just embarrassed
the the embarrassment side of it is
coming from
this is what the daughter is telling us
and
there has like there was actually an
incident today where
i know that the daughter had
to somebody her mom was there and her
mom refuses to let her talk to somebody
alone her mom
makes sure that she is there um but once
they all got home
i know that the parents were arguing and
i don't know what about but
and there's definitely some conflict
there so that's kind of you know we're
hearing one thing from the daughter kind
of seeing something going on on the
other side but we don't know how to
approach it with
the parents either so um this is a
pretty clear-cut moment
and um this is a moment when you're
going to get to
do a lot of good with some very simple
actions okay
so um as as grown-up as 17
feels and is articulate and smart
and on top of things as a 17 year old
can
can be i've worked with 17 year olds my
whole career
their children their kids okay
and so how they experience and feel
things is not always accurate
and in fact sometimes it can be way
distorted
between what they're feeling and
experiencing and hearing and reality
and what it doesn't appear
at the outset that she has had is a
place where she could sit down and be
safe with somebody and tell them hey i
need some support and help
and so what you're going to do is model
for her what that looks like and
you and or your husband are going to let
her know
that um she is that you're going to help
her get help but that help starts with
her
parents and you are going to have a
sit-down conversation with her parents
about your concerns about her mental
health
about her suggesting that she might hurt
herself
just to get some support and care and
that
you are gonna leave it up to mom and dad
to lean in and get some help
but that if um but you will be happy to
help
along the way and if mom and dad don't
get help then you're going to make that
call to her school
and the school's going to lean in and
get her the support that she needs okay
you've been triangulated into a mess is
what's happened
okay and you are probably cool
and you are probably beautiful and you
are probably
um hip and this 17 year old looks up to
you
and thinks your husband is cool because
he's an army guy now and
y'all are probably showing her more
attention than she's been shown in a
long time
and she has dragged you guys into them
into a um
a mess of a triangle if you will between
her and her parents
and what you have to do is to break that
triangle immediately get out of that
mess
she's asked for help i'm gonna get it
and that help starts with mom and dad
and if mom and dad are part of the
problem then you call the school and the
school will
lean in and get her the support and care
that she needs whether it's with a
school psychologist or counselor
whether it's calling in a school social
worker if there's abuse or things like
that going on
but you need to signal i'm going to
model what an adult does an adult gets
professionals involved adult gets a
parent involved
and an adult does not get dragged
underwater by a 17 year old
okay and what that will do is that will
free you up
she might get mad at you she might think
oh my gosh you ratted on me i hate you i
can't believe you
and then she will at some point come
around to understand that you cared
about her more than anybody else did
at this moment in her life and she will
love you for the rest of her life
for caring for her okay okay
but more um more deep
conversations and uh deep conversations
with
late teens are the best and the worst
they feel so
good because they're so rich and they
feel so
empowering to both of you because you
feel so good that someone's trusting you
with all this stuff
and she feels so good that an adult is
hearing her
and you got to get her with
professionals and with her parents
that's just the way that is so
um go for that i'm interested in how
that conversation goes with mom and dad
so give me a shout back i'd love to hear
how it goes and by the way we are
getting folks who are um
sitting in emails letting us know how
things go and we'll have a um
i'll be rolling some of those out as as
we move the show on in the next couple
of weeks
some of them are fascinating some of
them are great um actually all of them
have been great no one's called me and
been like you screwed my family up
i'm sure i'll get that at some point but
not yet